you actually grew up with quite a bit of
obstacles what happened I mean I one of
my biggest hurdles growing up in middle
score wore a back brace for two and a
half years like you know Louis Romy and
Michele ones yeah 7th and 8th grade and
so it was rough it was rough in that you
know the doctor was like if you don't
wear this you won't be able to dance so
I was like I have to dance I love
dancing and so my mom and I we went to
Macy's I bought clothes to go over my
back brace and I just embraced the
Braves yeah and I'd be like punch my
stomach like I'm as hard as a rock came
in yeah and so that helps me build my
confidence it just kind of not allow
people to I don't know bring me down or
anything or categorize very powerful
very powerful presence and I love that
and I also know you're very powerful
because you tried to start your own band
when you're a kid but you're too bossy
no here's the thing my I used my parents
printer like all of their ink you know
very expensive and I would print out
business cards for a business I didn't
have and I was for her and then I was
looking for band mates and I put fliers
all over it no inner spark no one calls
and I'm so I presented it all and now I
should have answered that flier I put up
a lot
and so yeah I was a one-person band for
a long time and it's interesting because
my my biggest weakness growing up was
that I I was gay and that I was
different from everyone else and now
it's become my biggest strength because
it's empowered me to I think I really
feared growing up because I was like
life is going to be so difficult and
people are just not going to understand
and going into my music career I was
just like why like if I'm scared
everyone else will be so I have to
embrace Who I am I have to be the brave
one because if I take that first step
everyone else will follow and they they
will hopefully you know feel inspired
and know that they can have a good life
and they don't have power it's suicide
they don't have to not love themselves
they can be loved and it's it's it's
about all these incredible powerful
women and just people in general taking
that first step and initiative to
showcase that absolutely I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this